we are learning exclusive new details
about how the jury in the landmark trial
of Harvey Weinstein reached this week's
decision to convict him a first-degree
criminal sexual assault and third-degree
rape only on CBS this morning juror
number nine told us it was not a simple
decision and the jurors did not consider
their verdict to be a referendum on the
me2 movement drew who asked us not to
use his last name spoke to us in New
York City yesterday a lot of people were
paying attention to this verdict there
was a lot of speculation about what it
means for the me2 movement what does it
mean to you for the meanto movement did
you all discuss that in the deliberation
job zero absolutely zero because it's
not the job and it's not what we were
asked to do and it would also it would
be an adulterer ation of the process to
take outside factors and have that weigh
on our decision-making process and
eventual findings and you know I have no
appetite or aspirations to be the voice
or face of both the jury and the larger
movement it's this case these people
this is our decision many of the victims
and their attorneys thank the jury
publicly who did that mean anything to
you no I took no joy in any aspect of it
you know this is this is a serious
matter and for for serious crimes and in
our next half-hour drew tells us how the
law pointed jurors to their verdict and
if he thinks Harvey Weinstein belongs in
prison that's ahead only on CBS this
morning
you know it's a type of thing when you'd
says a jury of your peers you never know
exactly what that means but I can say
this after spending time with him if he
is a type of person you want on a jury
someone who was that thoughtful that
deliberate and that smart you'll see
more you'll see more of what I'm talking
about later on yeah Claire took the
responsibility very seriously did
as an isolated case this is all that
matters the record world disappears it's
just the facts I'm Hill